ああああああ
par
me
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
今日私は
人生の最期に向き合うことの大切さについてお話をさせて頂きたいと思っています
今年の7月まで私横須賀市という町で8年間市長をやっていました
その中で
きあることに気付いたんです
それは
なんと横須賀市の市民の死亡率
100%がということなんです
苦笑い皆さんありがとうございます
そうです要は誰でも人生の最期を迎える時が来るという当たり前の話なんです
ぜひこの当たり前のことになさんにも向き合っていただきたい
そういった思いでですね今日は話をさせていただきたいと思います
ただあまり重たくならないようにですね
深刻になりすぎても意味がありませんから少し軽やかにお話をしていきたいとおもい
ます
まず皆さんに是非ちょっと手を上げていただきたいと思いますみなさんは
人生の最期
どこで迎えたいと思うのか選択肢よります
自宅で最期を迎えたできるだけ最後まで自宅にいたいという方
あるいは老人ホームやそういった介護施設などの施設で最期を迎えたいということ
あるいは病院で最期を迎えたい
これ正解がある話ではありませんからわからないというのでもいいと思います
ひとによっては公園のベンチとか
農場とかいらっしゃるかもしれませんがそれはちょっと選択肢から外させていただいて
ぜひ
会社の皆さん手をあげていただきたいですね
他の方々がどこで
どのぐらい最期を迎えたいと思っているか少し会場を眺めていただきたいと思います
じゃあ
最後自宅でできるだけ最後は迎えたいという方挙手をお願いいたします
結構いらっしゃいますね7割ぐらいでしょうか
ありがとうございますでは老人ホームなどの施設で最期を迎えたいという方
何かいらっしゃいますねありがとうございますじゃあ
病院で最期を迎えたいという彼だ
結構いらっしゃる1割ちょっとぐらいいらっしゃいますねありがとうございます
わからないという方と自信を持ってあげられた方も結構たくさんいらっしゃいますね
わからないこれも結構だと思います
実は今手を上げていただいた中で一番多かったのが
自宅でできるだけ最期を迎えたいという方々でした
でも実際
どこで多くの人が亡くなっているかと言うとそれは病院です
なんとその割合は73.9%
今それこそ7割ぐらいの方が自宅で最期を迎えたい
手を上げられたにもかかわらずつ
実際は病院で最期を迎えている方々が
これだけいらっしゃるということなんです
なぜこのような状況が起きるかというのはやはり時代背景があるんじゃないかと思い
ます
まず少子化ならぬ確かの時代です
少子化は
子どもが少なくなっていく確かは多くの人が死んでいくそういう時代です
団塊の世代そして団塊ジュニアと呼ばれる世代の皆さんがこれから徐々に高齢化をして
多くなくなっていくそういう時代になっていくわけです
そしてそういった皆さんが
病院で最期を迎えるようになると
実際生まれてくる赤ちゃんとそしてなくなる方々の差はすでに逆転をしています
なくてある方の方が増えている人口が減少しているという状況です
そうした中で核家族化医療の発展
そういったものを背景になくなる場所
人生の最期を迎える場所がどんどん変化をしてきました
この白い線が実は自宅で亡くなる方の割合です
戦後間もなくはなんと
8割以上の皆さんが自宅で最期を迎えていました
一方病院で最期を迎える方は1割弱9.1%それが直近のデータでは先ほど見たように
73.9%の方々が病院でなくなるようになっ
ていると
これと同じようなカードを描くもう一つのグラフがあります
少し話はそれますがそれは
生まれる場所です
やはり戦後はほとんど自宅で昔さん婆さんと呼ばれていた方々が取り上げていました
けれども今は98%以上
病院や産婦人科さんで出産しています
我々の生活から
命の始まる場所も終わる場所も切り離されるようになってきたということです
そうしたなかでこの
主こそ彼の市民の皆さんに
どこで最期を迎えたいかと皆さんにしたアンケートと同じようなアンケートをした
ところ
ご覧のように6割以上の方が
自宅でできるだけ自宅でというふうに答えられました
病院でと答えられた方々に是非ご注目いただきたいと思います
その割合は
15.4%です
ずう豪邸4%の皆さんは病院でなくなりたいその希望は叶えられているんでしょう
けれどもこのミスマッチ
15.4%しかいないのにもかかわらず実際は
73.9%もの方々が病院で妻を望まないのに
迎えてしまっているということです
ぜひイメージしてみてください
自宅で本当は最後まで暮らしたいのに両院に連れて行かれて入院をさせられて
そして仮に
満足なリハビリを受けられなかった時
関節がどんどん固まっていく自分の姿をイメージしてみてください
関節が固まって90度になって足も動かなくなって寝たきりになってそして誰も見舞い
に来てくれない
そういう自分の姿をイメージしてみてください
あるいは栄養を口から取ることができなくなって
点滴や
あるいはいいに穴を開けてええええを流し込んで生きながらえる自分の姿をぜひ
イメージしてみてください
あるいは
目や口が動かなくなってきて
半開きの状態で表情すら作ることができなくてコミュニケーションが取れなくなって
病院で生きながらえている自分の姿
ぜひイメージしてみてください
希望する方はほとんどいないのにいたとしても1割2割ぐらいなのに
病院で亡くなる方がこれだけ多くいる
この状況このギャップを何とかしたいということで
りょこ透かしは5年以上取り組んできました
そしてその結果
20万以上残しで全国一と
自宅で最期を迎えることができる割合が全国で1位となりました
その数22.9%
これはどのように実現することができたのか
それは
多くの関係者の皆さんが
自分のことあるいは家族の最後あるいは仕事で関わっている皆さんの最後その人生の
最後に
自分ごととして向き合おうとしてくださったからこそこのような結果が出たんだろう
同じように今日集まりのみなさんが自分の最後
身近な人の最後仕事で関わっている人の最期
地域の皆さんの最後そういう最後と向き合っていただければ
そういう地域社会をつくっていくことはヒットできるはずだと思っています
横須賀では
まず想いのあるお医者さんが声を上げました
ん
それこそ山の上の自宅でご自宅であってもあるいは車の通らない細い道の先にある家で
あっても訪問して診療してくださるお医者さんがたくさんいました
そしてさらには
一人でも
その患者さんのところに行く暑い日も寒い日も
入って甲斐甲斐しく看護師てくださる看護師の皆さんもいました
あるいは家族の負担を和らげるためにキャーマネージャーの方ヘルパーの方々の関わり
もすごく大事でした薬を運んでくださる薬剤師の皆さん
歯の治療をわざわざその後自宅でやってくださる歯医者さん
あるいは摂るべき栄養を
家族の方と相談をしてくださる管理栄養士の皆さん
地域の見守りの女としてに繊維の皆さん
町内会の皆さんそういう皆さんがぜひ
自宅でも最期を迎えられるような
地域社会にしていこうそういう自分のこととして向き合ってくださったからこそこうし
た
they 国で一番
在宅の最期の迎え方ということができるようになったということなんです
つまりやればできるということなんです
これからみなさんも自分の最後近しい人たちと向き合っていただければ
少しでも考える時間を作っていただければ
そういう世の中をつくることはできるんじゃないかなと
ぜひ一つエピソード紹介させてください
私も現場を知らなければいけないそんな思いでこの在宅での
治療というものどういうものなのか
現場を
お尋ねさせていただきましたこのマスクを買って食べた方
山崎さんちょっと仮の名前で恐縮ですけれどもこの方
膵臓がステージ4余命宣告2ヶ月
そういう中でご自宅での療養生活を希望されて病院から戻ってきました
私が訪問したのは3月の上旬3月の7日ぐらいだったと思います
どうして山崎さんご自宅での療養生活を希望されたんですがたん
お尋ねした
当たり前じゃないですかと
住み慣れたわが家であれば
何がどこにあるか全部わかるし近所の方々もいろいろ声をかけてくださるし何より
妻もいるした言って横に座った奥さん本当にこう
はにかんだ笑というかですね高
まあ苦笑いと言うんでしょうかそんな風に笑っています
ん
でこの紫色のジャケットを着ている方が
横されの在宅診療の第12社とも言うべき
千葉石千葉先生です
この千葉先生がいろいろなこの今後の薬の処方であるとか
療養のスケジュールとかお話しした後に
最後に
山崎さんと
人生の一持ちというものをぜひ帰ってください
そんなお願いされたんです
実は自分の診療所でそのをいろんな患者さんの人生の一文字というものを書いてもらっ
て展覧会を開こうと思っているんです
ですから
山崎さん是非その1文字を書いてください
実際後で聞いた話この山崎さんのためにその展覧会の開催を思いついたということなん
です
山崎さんは自衛官を退官していこう
耳がとても上手で地域の方々に教室を開いて外を教えていらっしゃった
ですからこの人文字の展覧会開催するからと言って
お願いをしたぶー
5月の松木
大祭をするということでした
私は当然あれって思いました3月の上旬余命宣告2ヶ月5月の松ということはそれ以上
生き音
そういう
メッセージなんだということだったんです
頑張っていきましょうとそういうメッセージをこの山崎さんにお届けをしてそして山崎
さんも
どんな子にしようかななんていう風に色々考えてらっしゃるような姿を今でも私は覚え
ています
そして5月の末になって千葉先生から私は連絡をいただきました
人生の一持ちの展覧会開催していますのでぜひ
計画に来てくださいということでした
私会場について
この山崎さんが書いた文字を拝見させていただきます
東京都のこの子
私これを見て
本当に涙が出てきたんですね
なぜならばこのプロ時は
その奥さんのお名前
京都さんというお名前だということを私は知っていたんです
山れ
一緒にいてくれてありがとうっていう思いが
あるいは
いろいろな楽しかったような思い出が込められていたりあるいは先に行くことを許して
くれよというお詫びの意味が込められていたりしたんじゃないかなと
私これを見ただけで泣けてきたんですが
さらに
土ば先生がおっしゃったのは3日前
山崎さんこの絵を見に来ることができたんです
そういうふうにおっしゃっていただいて教えてくださっ
そして私が入った日の前日に山崎さんが
亡くなられたと
それを聞いて本当にだけできましたでも
きっと
山崎さんは
幸せだったんじゃないかなと
皆さんにとったようにアンケート亡くなった人に取ることができませんが
奥さんと一緒に
人生の人も家を残すような京都さんと一緒に
最期を迎えることができていっ
本当に幸せだったんじゃないかなと
こういう地域社会を創ることあ
一人一人が
自分の人生の最期と
ドーム変えようと思っているかそう
向き合うことによってあるいは家族の方近しい方が
その最後どう迎えたいと思っているか考えることによって絶対に実現できるというふう
に思っています
ぜひ今日集まりの皆さんも1日の中1週間の中に
5分でもいいですからそういう時間を作っていただければ
病院で
72.9%の皆さんが望まないのにも関わらずなくなっている
望めば自宅でも最期を迎えることができるような世の中を作ることができると思います
のでぜひ宜しくお願いいたしますありがとうございました
[拍手]